[Music]
foreign
hey guys welcome to another episode of
the outdoor boys youtube channel today
we're going on a little bit of adventure
me and my boy
nathan here are going to spain on a
fishing trip
unfortunately tommy here has got school
so he can't go
and uh mommy's going to stay here with
him
that makes daddy sad i was going to miss
my mom
love you i'll see you in a little bit
nathan you think you can carry that back
all by yourself show me how it's done
buddy
thank you
we are going fishing we're gonna go
after some trophy carp
big monster wild carp and if we're lucky
we might be able to get some wells
catfish too we're gonna be fishing the
ebro river maybe doing some camping
northwest of barcelona and it is dirt
cheap right now
we were actually planning on going ice
fishing in michigan
but we looked at it and the cost of
going to spain
for eight days was less than going ice
fishing in michigan for three days
so we're like yeah let's do it so but
this will be kind of
an adventure this is the first time i'm
taking just nathan along on one of these
trips i took tommy to
japan this summer so i figure it's his
turn now
plus tommy's in school
that means nothing to me well we made it
here in one piece
we're gonna go get checked into the
hotel and find something for nathan here
to eat
yeah look at this well this will work
nate
look at this nate that's for cleaning
your butt
now we're going to get ourselves some
food we saw a place down there that
sells rectangle pizza and nathan's very
excited
should we get that one just let's just
yeah it's warm and look it's all frothy
it's got all these bubbles in it
now we gotta go get some souvenirs uh
this is one of our few free evenings on
this trip
so we gotta go get something for mom and
tommy and i also want to buy a spanish
kids book
hey you want to go play on that
playground yeah okay
look at this this is this would never
fly in the u.s this is awesome at this
it's a cinderella pop-up book big bad
wolf and the three pigs
we have a tradition that every time we
visit another country we want like to
buy kids books
in that country's language
let's pick somewhere to eat dinner look
this place has snails
i don't like tails
well guys it's eight o'clock and we're
heading out to dinner and uh
we're doing as the spanish do because
the spanish are night owls
a lot of stores and restaurants stay
open way later than they do in the u.s
and lots of people take a siesta in the
middle of the day
so it's kind of a late to bed late to
rise sort of culture
i might be down with that today hey
nathan you having fun
good all right here we are ibericus
there's a hum store yeah little ham
sandwiches there
that's that's ham that's from a pig's
leg
they age it and it gets tasty it's
really really tasty look at that they
got all the hams up there on this wall
you know what do i take a bite
these little sandwiches are so good you
know fresh baguette they rub
a tomato on on the inside of the bread
and then they put that that ham in there
just it's good
there we go that's a hundred grams of
ham right there
it's absolutely delicious amazing
it's all free range black pig that's fed
on acorns
it's got a really strong flavor to it
it's aged 20 months
that was really good and really
indulgent unfortunately nathan
did didn't like it much might have to
find him something else to eat
you want this apple yeah okay we'll get
you an apple
just can't get over how many families
are out
this late at night you know i've been in
places where they have hop and night
lives
but it's all 20 and 30 somethings you
know here's
one-year-olds and two-year-olds and
babies and strollers and
it's uh it's past nathan's bedtime oh
are you glad to be back at the hotel
yeah
well it's the end of two very long days
but we have absolutely had a ball
and me and nathan are just chilling here
unwinding and watching spanish cartoons
well good morning guys we went to bed at
9 30 last night
and i didn't set an alarm and figured
just wake up whenever
and uh it's quarter to 11
so we slept over 13 hours last night
geez well breakfast didn't end so well
poor little nathan really is feeling
sick because he blew chunks
all over himself and the table
and luckily that's pretty ninja fast
with a bowl but
uh yeah you're not feeling too well on
you so we're just going to go ahead and
drive to our next location and see if a
little car ride doesn't
make him feel better maybe he'll get a
little nap love you buddy
you okay there you need to throw up
poor little guy i told him not to lick
the handrail at immigration
no well but remember any problem you can
solve with wet wipes
is not a problem don't believe me just
ask a parent with teenagers doing better
buddy
yeah let's go
one thing that's a little freaky about
driving in spain is they use a white
line
to divide the two lanes so the shoulder
lane is white
and the middle lane is white as well and
so it feels like i'm driving in oncoming
traffic
because you know it's all white lines
and there's cars coming at me
the landscape here really reminds me of
utah and arizona
[Music]
oh there's the ebro river right there
this is ribaroya de ibrez the red banks
of the ibro river is where we're gonna
be staying
all right i think we're in the right
place look at that
all right that's a little tight well
here we are in reba de roya
and we're gonna go meet nick and we're
gonna be staying with him and he's gonna
be our fishing guide
here for the week and so we're going to
go check him out come on out bud
come on in nate come and see it say
hello to everybody
[Music]
he's feeling a little under the weather
here all right this is harry
hi harry harry just turned five oh
that's a grand age look at this david
it's like a castle in here
well nathan has been having a great time
with his new friend harry here
harry harry harry harry yeah
harry knows
[Music]
harry and nathan ran off and went
playing somewhere so they're having
a ball but look at this isn't this cool
look at that isn't that a gorgeous river
there are monsters in there
big old cats big old carp we found
someone
apparently harry is as much of a fan
of the d almighty river hunting videos
as nate is and so they've been walking
the streets of spain here
uh street treasure hunting so and
they've been very successful
by their standards you found all of that
look at that oh yeah locust yeah no it's
dead
hey nathan nathan you remember when i
told you we were reading about john the
baptist and how he eats locusts and
honey
yeah this is locust this is what he eats
he eats
wilkins he doesn't get it i don't want
to eat that
tomorrow we're going to get up and go
fishing you excited nathan
all right we'll see you guys in the
morning hey nathan did you have a good
night's rest
yeah you ready to catch big fish it's
gonna be exciting
awesome well we got the boys dressed and
fed and we're gonna go out to a tackle
shop get our
fishing licenses then we're gonna start
fishing so i'm excited
oh my goodness oh look at this all this
catfish gear look at that
that's a buoy float yeah those are pva
nuggets the
pva mash is a big jumbo mesh
oh yeah look at this
we got my fishing license and the boys
didn't destroy the shop so we
got mission accomplished here all right
guys we've gotta here stop at a grocery
store pick up some supplies
and i need a toothbrush it's been four
days i lost it i have no idea where it
went
look at that cart you want an orange
this is how you buy fruit in spain we go
number 26
that's oranges lay it on there
and then look at that it prints off the
sticker and i guess we put it on the bag
[Music]
all right next stop going fishing
[Music]
look at this overlook guys this is the
ebro river here
oh it's gorgeous look there's a castle
up on the hill
that water is so clear i swear if i had
a pair of binoculars i could
pick out every fish in there
this is good i found a bottle top
that nathan you still have the food in
your cheek for breakfast are you gonna
swallow that ever
i swear you didn't eat breakfast you
just stored it in your cheeks
all right big bag of homemade juicy
fruit boilies
or something oh that's a juicy fruit
flavoring yeah yeah
yeah the flavorings in the boilies yeah
i just put a little bit on the outside
of it as well really
center attraction especially in the
winter time yeah we got some serious
gear here look at this
by the way if you guys are interested in
coming here to spain and doing this
yourself i'm gonna put
nick's uh guide information in the
description for this video
oh you got a little stringer there yeah
and it sits off it sits off it like that
now that string right there in case you
don't know it's pva
which is water soluble like plastic made
out of like cornstarch
when it hits fresh water it dissolves so
all that string will just
liquefy into a biodegradable cornstarch
let's see if you can find them
you having a good time you warm
okay i'll shut the door well guys we put
in a pretty solid day here but
uh the boys are wet and cold and it's
dinner time so we're gonna
we're gonna call it and get them uh get
some dinner we don't want to push too
hard on our first day we'll burn them
out
nathan do you like this do you like
eating dinner in front of the fire
yeah well guys welcome to another
beautiful morning and we are getting
ready
to go fishing we're going to a different
spot a little further away today
and we're bringing the overnight gear so
it's
uh we're getting serious getting the
bivvy in bed chairs
sleeping bags fishing gear got to get it
all in there
this is the first time since i landed in
spain and we've seen any clouds
but it's supposed to be really nice
today supposed to be in the 60s well
guys we're headed to
this fishing spot which i don't know
anything about other than it's
upstream and about two hours away we're
excited it's gonna be our first
overnight trip
well we stopped in this little village
here and there's a tackle shop that's
open we're gonna grab
licenses for this county and uh check
out some gear too
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a serious doorbell yeah that's
what i'll use my cat fishing
oh look at this look nate
it's a catfish is there boats for
baiting up
oh look at these that's clunkers so many
things here i want to buy and so very
few things i can fit in my luggage
yo pick up your fish is that a swim away
we're driving through fields of rosemary
right now
it just smells amazing
i don't know what it is about this spot
but it just screams big fish to me
[Music]
easy right now i don't remember how i
told you how to play it
hey nathan you want to come help
you want to help
oh yeah that's that's yeah that's a big
fat
that's a fat fish
do you want to touch the fish look at
he's a big boy
cody says 37 in three quarters i'll take
that all day long
new personal best 37
oh jeez and three quarter
holes
look at that
all right should we get back let's get
him back
oh nice all right porky
oh big boy he's some help
that is awesome yeah that was a huge
fish man they hurt my back lifting that
thing
but i'm gonna go cast this back out and
we're gonna go get another one
i barely got our rods out we had one hit
um that didn't hook up and then
we just landed that fish and we haven't
been here long at all so
i think it's a good sign i just this
place just has all sorts of good vibes
about it luckily i've got myself a good
chair
nathan's got plenty of mud and sand to
play with we can dig in for the long
haul here
these are pig prints wild pigs that's a
cat
that's a kitty cat that's difficult
when them a white pigs come down here
the white [ __ ] fall into a hole
nice
[Music]
oh here we go buddy you got a fish
look what this is yes yeah come here you
want to hold him
yeah see cheese
this is a river chub okay i've never
caught one of these so this is my new pb
look at that that's a beauty
my favorite thing about spain so far is
the ham sandwiches
this is all i've been eating for like
all week it's been brilliant
oh this is more substantial no it's a
little it's a little carp
he's a baby top he's a baby carp yeah
all right should we put him back yeah
you know i'm actually
filming two different videos for my two
different youtube channels right now for
my other channel the catfish and carp
youtube channel
i'll be posting just the fishing stuff
you know with a lot more
detailed explanations of what gear we're
using and what we're doing i'll put
links in the description
to both all right nick's setting up the
uh the bivvy which is the
the carp fishing tent they actually sell
sleeping bags and and cots and tents
specifically designed for carp fishing
well the sun is beginning to set on a
very successful day but we're not giving
up we're going to be fishing all night
long
nick's over there cooking up a curry
which
i have to confess i'm very excited about
oh that smells fantastic already well
thank you very much nick this is great
i'll show it on the inside
we're about ready to freshen up our bait
before heading to bed and
reeled in the the pellet rod use these
for live bait for wells
yep i bet they do oh
you think you'll be warm yeah okay good
all right buddy why don't you lay down
and go to sleep okay
well it's the end of a great day and uh
we're still fishing i've got my alarms
on and the rods in the water and
something comes along and and bites it's
gonna wake me up hopefully and
we're out there and get it so uh but
anyway for tonight
it's good night and i'll see you guys in
the morning well good morning
sun just barely came up and uh
i think there's a little roach or
something on the end of this
end of this line there we go
hey bud you have a good night's rest
yeah you warm
you ready for some snake sausage what
the it's a snake this is like the second
time we've been eating snake recently
oh yeah we're good
we were sitting here in our tents last
night you could hear wild pigs
going crazy out there sounded like a
couple piglets got eaten or something it
was
it was crazy and there was foxes running
up and down and
cranes and storks lots of wildlife here
i found your fish
you're fishy well guys this is a pretty
nice way to watch your fishing rods
we're just sitting here in the
bivvy you can see right out the front
door
there's our rod pod just hanging out and
the fish bites
we're gonna be ready come on
you did it nate he just landed him good
job buddy
well then nathan that is a chunky fish
oh tommy's best is 36 and a half
maybe you can beat tommy's best here oh
man look at the hump on his back
quasimodo
85 35 close is i'm gonna kneel here
and hold him and you're gonna help me
put your hands underneath him okay
putting my hands underneath
okay they'd smile
[Music]
oh good let's get back
35 pass look at that beast good
good job buddy high five back back
good there you go
that was awesome good job nate
way to get your hand on a spanish ebro
carp
well the sun's properly set and things
have quieted down so we're gonna go back
to the house
and uh uh sleep in a bed tonight you
excited to go see your best friend
yeah i am excited to see my best friend
in the whole world
[Music]
[Applause]
hey buddy wake up
does that look good ethan yeah
oh yeah there was ice on the car
[Music]
last night was bitterly cold and i'm
glad we didn't stay in the tent
but uh the sun's coming out today looks
like we're gonna have
a beautiful final day
[Music]
there's a lovely 32 pound carp and he is
getting all sorts of wiggly on me huge
cart
oh should we put him back yeah yeah
32 pound car look at that sucker
nathan do you want to stay here yeah i
want to stay here forever
well it is a beautiful night the moon is
full and we are having a great time
but it's late and i need to get this boy
to bed because we have a long flight
tomorrow morning
well guys it's early morning and it's
time to head back to virginia are you
ready to see mama
[Music]
[Music]
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching